deputy national security advisor for the
trump administration
and author of revolution pete hexa
uh is fox and friends weekend co-host
and host of modern warriors on fox
nation
you got to go see that uh kt i got to go
to you
first because this is a serious issue
not getting enough coverage
it seems like to me that the russians
are moving
the cold war online now so
what is the response going to be from
the u.s
look i i just want to compliment you on
your opening statement you were spot on
because one of the most important things
that president trump did was to
have american energy independence which
drove down the price of oil and natural
gas
and it meant that russia's only way of
making money
evaporated so russia was broke the way
we won the cold war was bankrupting
russia
the way president trump had america
first policies was again to bankrupt
russia
so what should we do now the single most
important thing we could do if we really
wanted to put vladimir putin in a bad
place
would be to go after his cyber
capabilities and go after his economy
by again having america be energy
independent peter
thanks for being with me my friend um
attacks just last week worldwide
from these hackers and there's a
statement
actually this is the kremlin responding
to reuters
he said uh that they don't have enough
information on the cyber attack and
microsoft needs to answer more questions
including
how the attack is linked to russia what
do you say
you can have a lot of questions but
there's no doubt the kremlin was aware
and likely behind it nothing get nothing
happens
in moscow without ultimately the
blessing of the government there at
least the knowledge of it as you
acknowledged and
kt is entirely right i mean russia is
effectively a gas station with a flag
and when you cut off their energy
capabilities you them
when you increase sanctions as the trump
administration did you
make them more vulnerable and when you
supply actual weapons instead of
blankets
to their adversaries you're able to
block them i mean remember when barack
obama in 2012 said
uh to mitt romney the 1980s called and
they want their foreign policy back
the democrats have exploited russia when
they think it's politically advantageous
to them russia russia russia against
trump
but when they've been at the helm
they've allowed vladimir putin to expand
his influence
and expand what he wants to be is the
restoration of the soviet union that's
that is ultimately his goal he said it
outright
their democrats have no tools in the
toolbox to actually fight back will we
respond
listen inferior adversaries go to the
tactics that can work for them based on
their capabilities
cyber is what vladimir putin thinks he
can use because he doesn't believe the
bide administration
will fight back and thus far he's been
right unfortunately
so i want to stay with pete for a second
because i i think you hit on a couple
good points there
uh one is i want to understand the
difference between
words and action because you know
back when donald trump was president
there was a lot of
i want to work with russia meanwhile
he's literally tearing them apart
policy wise now you got joe biden that's
talking tough talking a real big game
but policy is really not reflecting that
so
what what is the strategy there
well speaking loudly but carrying a
little stick has never been
uh the approach that you want to take
and you know what president trump
as kt knows better than anybody was
derided by his critics for saying
he's trying to dismantle nato when the
only thing he did was reinvigorating it
reminding member states that they had to
pay up for their own defense because you
can't just
you know stand on the backs of the
american military for the next 50 years
as well
so president trump was willing to engage
because he recognized there's other
places we could constructively
potentially work with the russians but
he knew
all along that they're an adversary who
you have to stare down toe to toe
yeah you're right they wanted a free
ride and and he
wanted them to share the responsibility
i think that's pretty reasonable
kt what should the response be before
this convention he doesn't have a lot of
time
and he can't be weak so what should he
do
well he won't do it but what he should
do lawrence is go to putin and say
okay the solar winds hack the colonial
pipeline hack the microsoft hack you say
you have nothing to do with it we don't
believe you
and in fact we are going to take action
um to defend ourselves and to have
deterrence we're going to take action
against your capabilities
and guess what unless you prove to us
that you're not responsible we assume
you are responsible
yes pete i got to ask you um if
you were on the battlefield served us
honorably
why isn't there more investment for
cyber defense where are we going wrong
as a
as a country it just doesn't seem like
we're doing all we can do
well uh we do have some capabilities
that we should be using
to hit back at vladimir putin and the
russians right now we should be
you know more than commensurate with
what they've done
just like israel does to the iranian
nuclear capabilities do what we need to
do
where we need to do it frankly the
military-industrial complex is really
good at building conventional weapons
there's a lot of money in
conventional weapons and ultimately
that's where a lot of our resources go
and rightfully so listen
we can't ignore the communist chinese
who are a number one in who we will need
to share down in the future they have
literal global ambitions whereas
vladimir putin's trying to expand his
sphere of influence
but cyber is where our enemies are going
to try to hit us they realize we're
vulnerable and we better double down in
our investments there we're going to pay
the price see pete i see what you did
there you didn't say we we couldn't
you're saying that we're not
so we do have the capabilities we just
not you know
doing it anyway unleashing that's right
thank you ktmp don't forget to catch p's
new episode of modern warrior
reflections available now on fox nation
and if you are a veteran
or an active duty military fox nation is
offering you a free year on the platform
just go to foxnation.com
to sign up hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else